hey youtubers is charlie so long overdue
channel update for all the awesome stuff
that's going to be happening this winter
so think of this is like an emergency
awesome trailer if you've only been
watching for a little while or you're
not sure what's going on you have to
imagine you know what would it look like
if Deadpool had his own YouTube channel
one he would probably make fun of
everybody and they would probably a lot
of stabbing and since YouTube friends on
stabbing most of my time is spent just
trying to make funny easter egg videos
or explanations a big comic book arcs or
science fiction genre like I'm a big
game of thrones fan very fantasy so the
big thing that's happening right now is
that most of television is coming back
so you have flash you have ghostwriter
the other DC TV shows so usually what I
do is I'll post videos for episodes the
night that they air unless I think it's
absolute hot garbage there aren't that
many shows that I still watch that I
think are hot garbage this is meant to
be fun so I just try to make it as fun
as possible that's like one of the seven
deadly sins on my youtube channel being
a bummer is punishable by beheading so
while a lot of television is coming back
in the next couple weeks like flash
arrow Supergirl legends of tomorrow
Marvel's television stuff is kind of
already up and going but most of the
movies like DC and Marvel like
spider-man homecoming thor ragnarok
Justice League or in the process of
shutting down over the next couple of
months so the types of videos that I
make for movies and for TV shows just
change depending on what time of year it
is in what you guys want to talk about
so if you're new to the channel and
you're not sure what kind of videos I
make or what I'm going to be doing week
to week as we work into the fall you can
look in my videos page and just kind of
scan down briefly and it'll give you a
pretty good idea for what's going on you
know trailer videos easter egg videos
funny mashup videos like Thor's hammer
or an explanation of like some big real
life WTF twist like when Marvel Studios
kind of split in two and went off by
itself to start making its films without
oversight or like the big Sony
announcement when they announced that
spider-man would be joining the Marvel
Universe so if there are any videos that
you guys don't see me making that you
really want me to do just let me know in
the comments but generally it's going to
be a really fun winter there's so much
awesome stuff that's coming back so if
you are just finding me for the first
time
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
do giveaways week to week for Marvel DC
Game of Thrones Walking Dead stuff so
the best way to find out what videos i'm
working on day to day if you're not sure
like what i'm going to be posting later
in the day is twitter facebook i usually
post updates on what i'm working on
youtube is in the process of rolling out
some new features that'll make a little
bit easier to find out what the hell's
going on day to day but i don't think
that that's going to be a thing for at
least another couple months anytime
youtube rolls out some new cool feature
it always takes months for it to roll
out so like you may have seen the new
end cards there's like new end cards
that you can click on if you're on your
mobile phone but it's not on every
operating system it doesn't work in
every browser right all that stuff is
included in the description but if you
have any questions about the stuff that
i'm going to be doing this winter just
let me know in the comments but comic
book TV shows movies genres stuff like
Game of Thrones Walking Dead pretty safe
bet that I'll be making videos about
everything the only time I won't make a
video about something is if I feel like
it's really boring or there's something
else that's like way more interesting
you may notice that I do try to
alternate between Marvel and DC videos
and other stuff too so the only
exception to that is if Marvel or DC
decides that it wants to give us a heart
attack and just drop a bunch of trailers
or something crazy all on the same day
for a bunch of different stuff that's
really the only time you'll see like a
bunch of DC videos without seeing any
marble videos or vice versa like with a
bunch of Marvel in 0 DC but generally I
try to keep it pretty even so it's going
to be a really awesome winter there's
more comic book stuff happening now than
ever before so I try to stay on top of
everything but if there's something you
think that I'm missing or I haven't made
a video about something feel free to
spam the comments so say new round of
the giveaway starts now it's a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video if
you're not sure how giveaways work
generally all you have to do to enter a
giveaway is be a subscriber and leave a
comment giveaways are only open to
people that are subscribers they are
international so if you don't live in
the United States you can still
participate in giveaways I just try to
make them as easy and painless as
possible winners are usually given a
shout out in the next
video so like I'll start a flash
giveaway on Tuesday when I post my first
flash video the winner will be announced
when I post my next DC video after that
it's the same thing for Marvel giveaways
to so I now it's a Marvel give away the
winner gets announced in the next Marvel
video so again I there's so much crazy
stuff coming the rest of the year it's
going to be great well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
spider-man homecoming Iron Man easter
egg and you can click here to get ready
for the flash season 3 thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight